[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin einen schönen guten Abend
freut mich sehr dass Sie dabei sind das
sportliche Update übernimmt heute Katja
streso und wir heute für Sie vorbereitet
Sorge wegen Omicron Europa reagiert mit
flugbeschränkungen auf die neue Corona
Variante in Deutschland gibt es die
ersten Fälle
Probleme beim Impfstoff Nachschub viele
Ärzte klagen wegen der boomenden
Impfkampagne über Lieferprobleme
[Musik]
und gelungener Biathlon Start Denise
Herrmann erkämpft sich zum Saisonauftakt
Platz 3
[Musik]
in dieser akuten Pandemie Lage fordern
führende Wissenschaftler heute die
Politik auf schärfere Maßnahmen im Kampf
gegen Corona zu ergreifen gleichzeitig
schafft Omicron also das neue
Coronavirus weltweite Beunruhigung in
München gibt es die beiden ersten
bestätigten Fälle der neuen Variante in
Frankfurt einen Verdachtsfall für hoch
bis sehr hoch schätzt eine EU-Behörde
das Risiko einer Ausbreitung in Europa
ein und darum setzen die EU-Staaten auf
flugbeschränkungen mit Tests mit
Quarantäne und Kontakt Nachverfolgung
Deutschland stuft ab morgen 8 Uhr
starten im Süden Afrikas als Virus
Varianten Gebiete ein unter anderem
Namibia Botswana Mosambik und Südafrika
wo Omicron zuerst festgestellt wurde
Volker Duczek berichtet
zu Christiane Provinz und Alexandra von
Samson Sager nimmt die Afrikareise heute
in Johannesburg eine unerwartete Wende
den Urlauberinnen Drohnen 14 Tage
Quarantäne wenn sie am Abend nach
Deutschland zurückkehren schuld ist
Omicron die neue wohl aggressivere Virus
Variante die in Südafrika grassiert
baden gehen davon aus dass 85 von ihnen
Corona haben jeder 7. ob es sich um
diamicron Variante handelt ist noch
unklar die Infizierten sind in einem
Hotel isoliert
das Virus weh.
1.1.5 29 bereits in Deutschland durch
zwei Südafrika Rückkehrer die in München
gelandet sind das bestätigte vor wenigen
Minuten das bayerische
Gesundheitsministerium alle Rückkehrer
werden seit gestern getestet
es wurden dann bei anderen die weiterhin
hier bei uns bleiben Quarantäne
Anordnungen ausgesprochen es wurden die
Gesundheitsämter mit einbezogen ist
wurden die Daten erhoben so dass wir aus
unserer Sicht alles getan haben was
rechtlich möglich war die neue Virus
Variante sagt zu nehmen für Nervosität
und das sind jetzt die aktuellen Corona
zahlen für Deutschland das
Robert-Koch-Institut meldet
67125 Neuinfektionen binnen eines Tages
das sind gut 3200 mehr als vergangenen
Samstag innerhalb von 24 Stunden sind
303 Todesfälle hinzugekommen die 7 Tage
Inzidenz liegt jetzt bei
444, drei immer mehr Politiker und
Wissenschaftler fordern strengere
Maßnahmen dazu Ines Trams
der Weihnachtsmarkt brummt hier in
Berlin ist er noch erlaubt und das
Weihnachtsgeschäft es läuft an doch wie
lange noch wird all das geöffnet sein
der Einzelhandel fürchtet einen erneuten
Lockdown um den zu verhindern fordert
sein Verband nun eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht es gelte Wirtschaft und
gesellschaftliches Leben
aufrechtzuerhalten
Anlage die wir haben aufgrund des
Pandemie Verlaufes fordern wird wirklich
eine allgemeine Impfpflicht die
umgesetzt werden soll weil in Abwägung
der Maßnahmen die jetzt erforderlich
sind sehen wir deutlich auch mit dem
Blick auf einen möglichen Lockdown auf
die Schließung der Geschäfte dass es auf
jeden Fall sinnvoller ist jetzt mit mehr
impfen gegen diese Pandemie an zu
arbeiten genau einen solchen Lockdown
fordert die Leopoldina die renomierte
naturwissenschaftlich medizinische
Gelehrten Gesellschaft massiver Kontakt
Beschränkungen auch für geimpfte und
genießen eventuell vorgezogene
Weihnachtsferien wie viel Schuhe jetzt
die vierte Welle zu brechen haben dich
funktioniert und eigentlich fordern wir
sie viel Kontakt Beschränkungen also
wenn man ehrlich ist ein Lockdown für
etwa drei Wochen den man massiv putzen
sollte zum Boostern die regionalen
Unterschiede sind euch sehr groß dass es
eine politische Entscheidung aber
sinnvoll wäre eigentlich flächendeckend
die Wissenschaftler
[Applaus]
mittenmang sind bei vielen gar nicht
erst angekommen über die Impfstoff Lücke
und die Aufregung Peter Kunz das
Wochenende durch impfen in dieser
kritischen Corona Situation so war das
geplant in Ibbenbüren
Nordrhein-Westfalen aber nein jetzt ist
Samstag Vormittag gleich ist Schluss wir
haben kein Impfstoff mehr es ist zuende
sie haben heute sehr viele erst im
Pflege die wenn ich für Impfungen auch
in Niedersachsen die Impfkampagne
ausgebremst weil versprochener Impfstoff
nicht kam wir haben Termine gemacht
haben Patienten einen bestellt und jetzt
wird weniger geliefert als versprochen
worden ist so können wir natürlich die
Pandemie schlecht bekämpfen wenn wir
keine Munition haben die Kritik geht an
den geschäftsführenden Minister der
heute für Booster Impfungen war und
zugab dass Sand im Getriebe ist ist
jetzt zum Teil auch internistisches tvos
mal ein zwei Tage länger dauert in der
Versorgung sind im Moment Anfang
nächster Woche 14 Millionen Unfall
Impfdosen die dir zuzusagen zum Teil
schon vor Ort sind oder auf dem Weg zu
vor Ort sind Berlin offensichtlich
überfordert von einer guten Nachricht
dass ich mehr Ärzte für die Info
Aufholjagd gemeldet haben als erwartet
100 000 bundesweit die Nachschub
brauchen auch in Brandenburg wir sind
heute am Samstag haben sich Kommunen
ausgeholfen haben Impfdosen zur
Verfügung gestellt da wo es fehlte damit
die Angebote realisiert werden konnten
sechs parallele im Straßen in
Brandenburg an der Havel in einem
Bundesland unter dem Schlusslicht dann
beim Impfen impfstoffmangel ist auch aus
Sicht der Landesregierung die falsche
Botschaft in einer Zeit in der die
Kampagne gerade doch selbst ihren
Booster bekommt
von Impfstoffen zu ihm nachweisen
allerdings gefälschten laut Welt am
Sonntag blüht der Schwarzmarkthandel mit
ihnen seit Jahresbeginn mehr als 2.500
Fälle die meisten in den vergangenen
Wochen seitdem gelten ja vielerorts 2G
Regeln die nur geimpften und genießen
den Zugang zu öffentlichen Orten
ermöglichen auf einer
Delegiertenkonferenz in Berlin hat die
Grüne Jugend ihren Mitgliedern empfohlen
den Ampel Koalitionsvertrag zuzustimmen
GRÜNE JUGEND Chef gino's sagte der
Vertrag öffne ein erstes Fenster für
Verbesserung Vorbehalte gab es aber
gegen die geplante sozial und
Klimapolitik die grüne Mitglieder können
in einer Urabstimmung noch bis zum 6.
Dezember über die Vereinbarungen
entscheiden
auch die Jusos haben sich auf ihren
Bundeskongress in Frankfurt mit dem
Koalitionsvertrag der Ampel beschäftigt
SPD Kanzlerkandidat Schulz war beim
Parteien Nachwuchs für das gemeinsame
Papier mit Grünen und FDP JUSO Chefin
Rosenthal sagte ihm die kritische und
solidarische Unterstützung der
Organisation zu zuvor hatten sich einige
Jusos unzufrieden über den
Koalitionsvertrag
geäußert und
wir gehen rüber zu Andreas Kynast fährt
den User Kongreß erfolgte glaube ich
langsam zu Ende geht soll ja timer
richtig laute Kritik formuliert worden
sein worüber denn genau Andreas
daran dass es zuwenig Flüchtlingsschutz
gebe im Koalitionsvertrag zu wenig
Mieterschutz zu wenig um Verteilung also
kurz gesagt zu wenig SPD und das haben
die Jungs Russia Olaf Scholz ziemlich
sagte ich ziemlich heftig ins Gesicht
gesagt manchmal auch gerufen und der hat
das sehr ernst genommen denn die Jusos
sind so mächtig so wichtig wie noch nie
die neue Bundestagsfraktion besteht zu
einem Großteil aus Jusos und zweitens
weiß ja kaum einer besser als die
ehemalige Hassfigur der Jusos Olaf
Scholz welche Dynamik entstehen kann
wenn die Jusos eine Koalition nicht
wollen Stichwort Kevin Kühnert der hier
gerade spricht aber anders als beim
endlosen Kampf gegen die groko gab es
hier heute nicht eine einzige
Wortmeldung die die Ampel grundsätzlich
ablehnt und wenn das nicht mal der Jusos
Bundeskongress macht dann muss sage ich
jetzt mal Olaf Scholz vor dem
SPD-Bundesparteitag nicht bei mir sein
dann steht die Ampel wohl auf Grün schön
danke Frank wollte Andreas Kynast
könnte die entscheidende Runde im
Tarifstreit im öffentlichen Dienst sein
Gewerkschaften und Arbeitgeber haben in
Potsdam die dritte Verhandlungsrunde
gestartet Verdi und der Beamtenbund dbb
fordern für die mehr als 1 Million
landesbeschäftigte 5% mehr Geld
mindestens aber 150 € monatlich im
Gesundheitswesen 300 € mehr die
Arbeitgeber legten bislang kein Angebot
vor Markus groß und Dorte Störmann
berichten letzte Vorbereitung vor der 3.
Tarifrunde Jens Peters ist fest
entschlossen die Fachmann im
brandenburgischen Gesundheitsministerium
will dass die Forderungen der
Gewerkschaften eins-zu-eins durchgehend
die Inflation seit schon spürbar Corona
mehr als kräftezehrend für uns durch
solche
tagtäglich und der Arbeitgeber sagt
einfach nö also ist er dabei bei der
Kundgebung heute Mittag vom Potsdam
Tagungshotels gleich geht es hier um
mehr Geld für gut 1,1 Millionen
Beschäftigte mit Warnstreiks hatten sie
in den letzten Wochen gezeigt was kommen
könnte wenn sie bald nicht mehr bekommen
sollen wir definitiv streiten und so
wird die Tarifgemeinschaft der Länder
die TdL in Potsdam lautstark Empfang vor
den Kameras demonstrative
Gesprächsbereitschaft dabei wurde war
das
doch alle hier wissen bislang gab es von
ihm nicht das Geringste Angebot
mindestens 2,4
wie lange die Verhandlungen dauern
völlig offen
auf den Tag genau vor 60 Jahren nahmen
die Firma Grünenthal das Schlafmittel
Contergan vom Markt dennis war klar dass
das Schlafmittel die Ursache für
tausende schwere Missbildungen bei Babys
war opfer und Angehörige leiden bis
heute für sie aber auch für viele andere
geschah heute etwas Außergewöhnliches
nach all den Jahrzehnten entschuldigte
sich die Eigentümerfamilie zum ersten
Mal bei den Opfern Susana Santina
für sie alle ist es ein emotionaler Tag
vor 60 Jahren Medikament vom Markt
genommen dass sie zu Behinderten gemacht
hat
Schulter zu überwinden
ich kann nicht mehr jede Tasse hochheben
das Schlaf und Beruhigungsmittel
Contergan war ab 1957 erhältlich
rezeptfrei in dieser Zeit kommen mehr
als tausend Babys mit schweren
Missbildungen zur Welt bis festgestellt
wird dass das Medikament Contergan dafür
verantwortlich ist vergehen vier Jahre
Grünthal bezahlte damals eine
Entschädigung von 100 Millionen D-Mark
heute können Betroffene wie Alfonso
Fernandez bei Grünenthal finanzielle
Unterstützung beantragen etwa für
medizinische Hilfsmittel auch der
61-Jährige kann wegen starker Schmerzen
immer weniger selbst machen und es zum
grünen Tal enttäuscht
mal bei den Kontakten Geschädigten
entschuldigt für das große leid dass
ihnen durch ihr Medikament zugefügt
wurde eine Geste auf die sie 60 Jahre
gewartet haben
überaus erfolgreich waren die deutschen
Kombinierer beim Weltcup in Finnland
Terence Weber gewann vor Eric Frenzel
und Vincent Vinzenz Geiger beim
Zweierbob Weltcup in Innsbruck liegt der
Francesco Friedrich vor Teamkollege
Johannes Lochner jetzt noch mehr
Wintersport morgen
beim Weltcup in Finnland noch Platz drei
Gewinner der Japaner kobashi vor dem
Slowenen lanisek das Gelbe Trikot des
Weltcup führenden verteidigt Kai Geiger
er wird Fünfter
ein riesiger Erfolg für die deutsche
Langläuferin Katharina Hennig sie wird
dritte beim Weltcup-Auftakt in Finnland
über zehn Kilometer und qualifiziert
sich damit direkt für Olympiasiegerin
Frida Karlsson aus Schweden vor der
großen Favoriten Therese Johaug aus
Norwegen
Fußball und die bisherigen Ergebnisse
dieses 13 Bundesligaspieltag Wolfsburg
Dortmund 123 Bochum Freiburg 2 zu 1
Greuther Fürth Hoffenheim 3 zu 6 Köln
Gladbach vierzueins Hertha Augsburg eins
zu eins am Abend Bayern Bielefeld
ausführlich im Aktuellen Sportstudio
bereits gestern Stuttgart Mainz
zweizueins die Tabelle Dortmund aktuell
noch vorn die Bayern können am Abend
aber wieder vorbeiziehen dahinter
Freiburg Leverkusen und Hoffenheim die
zweite Hälfte Köln vor Gladbach und
Bochum ganz unten Augsburg auf dem
Relegationsplatz dann Bielefeld und
Fürth ja alles zum Spieltag im Aktuellen
Sportstudio
dass die frisch gekürten para Sportler
und Sportlerinnen des Jahres Alters von
23 Uhr dreißig Uhr an und noch dies
Tischtennis Timo Boll steht in Houston
Texas im WM-Viertelfinale kampflos weil
sein Gegner in Quarantäne musste und
Einkommen der Gegner der US-Amerikaner
Canada verhinderte ein rein deutsches
Viertelfinale denn er besiegte Ruwen
Filus in fünf Sätzen das dann heute
Nacht das Viertelfinale und morgen
wieder Wintersport von 10:15 Uhr an dann
vielen Dank
morgen an dieser Stelle Barbara hallweg
das gesamte heute 9 cm sagt danke fürs
zuschauen und wünsche noch ein
entspanntes Adventswochenende auf bald
[Musik]
guten Abend
morgen fällt noch Schnee hier südlich
der Donau sonst gibt es
schneeregenschauer und ab und zu
vielleicht sogar mal ein kleines
Schneeregen Gewitter hier im Nordwesten
die Sonne macht sich eher rar und am
besten klappt das mit dem Sonnenschein
wollen noch im nordlichen Brandenburg am
Montag ändert sich noch nicht so viel am
Dienstag aber wird es von Nordwesten
stürmisch und in Süddeutschland rot
Schneesturm guten Abend